- [Narrator] This is the collared lizard.
The two black bands around
their neck give them their name.
Collared lizards can actually
run on their hind legs
and reach up to 15 miles per hour.
Their tails are used
for balancing themselves
when they are up and sprinting.
They are a medium-size lizard,
reaching up to a foot
and a half in length.
Native to western North
America, they prefer to live
in rocky habitats with sparse vegetation.
Today they are widespread,
but only a few decades ago
their population was declining.
Clearing land as a form of fire prevention
has greatly helped its population rebound,
as they need open, rocky
habitats to survive.
This is the collared lizard.
(cheerful piano music)